สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะสดีนักเรียนใช่ครูเรียมวันนี้วันอะไร
คะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 4
อืเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ตุลาคมค่ะเปลี่ยนเดือน
แล้วใช่ค่ะปีพ.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะค.ศ
ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครูเรียมตอนนี้
14 น 38 น
ค่ะ
1438 นผู้หญิงตกใจมากเลยอ่ะค่ะครูเรียม
เดือนตุลาคมแล้วเหรอคะเวลาผ่านไปเร็วมากๆ
ใช่เร็วมาก
อืแล้วเรามีความสุขใช่มีความสุขนะเรามี
ความสุขใช่มยเวลาก็เลยผ่านไปเร็วเวลาเวลา
ที่เวลามันผ่านไปเร็วๆเราก็จะรู้สึกว่า
เออเราจะเกบขึ้นอีกปีนึงแล้วหรอเราไม่ชอบ
เลยเนาะเ้อเวลาเราเป็นเด็กๆอ่ะเราจะอยาก
ให้เวลาผ่านไปเร็วๆเราอยากโตใช่อยากโต
เป็นผู้ใหญ่
อืแล้วแบบตอนนี้เรียมก็ถึงแบบหลัก 3 แล้ว
อ่ะเรียมแค่ 3 เอง
ค่ะครุหญิงจะไป 4 แล้วค่ะครูเรียวครู
เรียวเพิ่งจะมา 3 เองอืเรียมก็เลยรู้สึก
แล้วเออมันเปลี่ยนมันเนาะแล้วแบบว่าพอเรา
โตขึ้นเราก็เริ่มคือเขาคบอกว่าครูเลียงเ
บอกว่าเขาจะเช็คได้นะว่าเราเริ่มรู้สึก
ว่าเราแก่เนี่ยก็คือเราเริ่มจะคิดถึงอดีต
แล้วอ่ะ
โเออมันพอเราแบบโตแล้วก็ใช้เวลานานขึ้น
เราก็จะได้เห็นว่าตอนนี้เป็นยังไงเมื่อ
ก่อนเป็นยังไงเราก็จะเห็นว่ามันแตกต่าง
กันใชอืมแล้วเราก็จะชอบพูดว่าแบบว่าเนี่ย
เด็กสมัยนี้เด็กสมัยนี้มันเหมือนกับสมัย
นี้แล้วก็สมัยเราอ่ะมันไม่เหมือนกันไงเรา
เริ่มชอบพูดเนี่ยเด็กสมัยนี้ชอบพูดเสียง
ดังอย่างเงี้ยเรานี่ฉันแก่แล้วเหรอฉันพูด
คำว่าเด็กสมัยนี้
อ่าเพราะว่าเด็กๆคงไม่พูดคำนี้อเด็กเค้า
ไม่พูดไงเพราะว่าเค้าก็เค้าก็ยังอยู่ใน
ยุคปัจจุบันนี้อ่ะเค้ายังไม่ได้เหมือนแบบ
สมัยนี้แล้วก็สมัยก่อนใช่มยพะเคยังอยู่ก็
ก็เาก็โตมาพร้อมกับสมัยนี้มันไม่ได้มี
อะไรที่เปลี่ยนจนเค้ารู้สึกว่ามันไม่
เหมือนสมัยก่อนแต่ว่าครูหญิงครูเรียม
เนี่ยเราก็เริ่มรู้สึกว่าอุ๊ยสมัยนี้กับ
สมัยเรา
เหมือนกันนะอือืแบบพูดแบบไม่อยากพูด
เดี๋ยวเขารู้ว่าแบบผ่านมาเยอะเะอายุเยอะ
อายุเยอะขึ้นอายุเยอะขึ้นอแต่ก็พูดให้แบบ
เรียมว่าหลายๆคนก็อาจจะมีประสบการณ์คล้าย
ๆกันที่เมื่อก่อนน่ะหรือว่าสมัยก่อนน่ะ
เราจะมีความทรงจำตอนเด็กอืที่มันไม่มี
แล้วกอนนี้
อืมใช่ค่ะครูหญิงจำได้เลยนะคะสิ่งที่ครู
หญิงน่าจะไม่เหมือนกับเด็กๆตอนนี้แน่นอน
ก็คือตอนูหญิงเป็นเด็กเนี่ยไม่มีโทรศัพท์
ค่ะอือืใช่ไม่มีโทรศัพท์แล้วไม่มี
อินเตอร์เน็ตเราเราก็ยังไม่รู้เลยว่า
โทรศัพท์คืออะไรอูแค่บ้านเรามีทีวีเราก็
รู้สึกว่าแบบว้าวบ้านฉันมี
ทีวีอืมแล้วอสมัยก่อนถ้าครูหญิงจะจะพูด
แบบอยู่ไกลๆกันน่ะไม่มีโทรศัพท์ทำยังไง
สมัยนั้นต้องเขียนจดหมายมยคะใช่ๆต้องเอา
กระดาษมาต้องเอากระดาษมากระดาษ
ปากกาเขียนแล้วก็เขียนอืแล้วก็ส่งจดหมาย
เอแล้วแล้วรุ่นครูเรียมอ่ะยังเขียนจดหมาย
หาเพื่อนมั้ยเขียน
นะคะเขียนจดหมายติด
สแตมป์แล้วก็ไปหย่อนในตู้ตู้ไปรษณีย์อื
ทันนะเมื่อก่อนเวลาที่เรียมดูรายการทีวี
ใช่มยเรี่มก็ยังเขียนจด
หมายเขียนจดหมายไปในรายการทีวี
โอตอนนี้ไม่มีสมัยนี้ไม่
มีไม่มีแล้วสมัยนี้แบบไม่ใช่แค่เขียนจด
หมายอย่างเดียวนะโทรไปในรายการทีวีก็ไม่
มีแล้วมยคะส่วนใหญ่ก็จะเป็นเหมือนส่ง
คอมเมนต์อะไรข้อความเออคอมเมนต์หรือว่า
ส่งข้อ
ความในเพจ Facebook  Twitter ของแต่ละราย
การใช่ๆเออโหแต่ว่าแบบเดี๋ยก็เลยผู้หญิง
ชอบแบบไหนมากกว่ากัน
อืมันก็เป็นความตเค้าเรียกมันก็เป็น
ประสบการณ์ที่ไม่เหมือนกันน่ะนะมันก็แค่
มันเปลี่ยนไปแค่นั้นแหละค่ะมันก็คงไม่แบบ
บางครั้งมันก็อาจจะคิดถึงตอนเด็กๆแบบสมัย
ก่อนว่าแบบเออชีวิตเราไม่ต้องอยู่กับ
เทคโนโลยีตลอดเวลาเนาะเราก็ยังอยู่ได้เลย
อ่ะแต่ทำไมตอนนี้เราต้องอยู่กับเทคโนโลยี
ตลอดเวลาแต่ว่ามีเทคโนโลยีมันก็ดีเหมือน
กันมันก็เลยทำให้เรารู้สึกว่าอุ้ยสมัยนี้
กับสมัยก่อนเนี่ยมันไม่เหมือนกันเลยนะใช่
ไม่เหมือนกันเลยตอนนั้นที่ครูหญิงไปโรง
เรียนครูหญิงได้เงินไปโรงเรียนกี่บาทสมัย
ก่อน 5 บาท
มหรือโอู้้หญิงไม่ได้ถึง 10 บาทแน่นอนน่ะ
ผู้หญิงจำได้นะหรือว่าผู้หญิงได้ 10 บาท
ว่ะจำไม่ค่อยได้ประมา 4 ขวบมย 4  5 ขวบ
อุ๊ยผู้หญิงไปโรงเรียน 6 ขวบนะครูเรียมอ
จริงหรอใช่ๆู้หญิงไปโรงเรียนอายุ 6 ขวบ
อ่ะก็คือเรียนอนุบาล 1 ปีแล้วก็ขึ้นป 1
เลยอ๋อ
ออแต่ว่าู้หญิงมีเพื่อนที่อายุเท่ากันนะ
คะแล้วก็ไม่ได้อยู่กรุงเทพฯเหมือนกันด้วย
อ่ะเาก็ไปโรงเรียนตั้งแต่ 4 ขวบแต่ทำไม
โรงเรียนแต่ทำไมกครูหญิงไปโรงเรียน 6 ขวบ
ไม่รู้อ่ะไม่รู้โเรียมอ่ะไปโรงเรียนตอน
อายุ 3 ขวบอู้หูเด็กมากเพื่อนในห้องเดียว
กันก็คืออายุ 4 ขวบค่ะ
เออก็ก็จะเรียนมีเพื่อนเยอะใช่มั้ยแต่คุ
หญิงอ่ะไปโรงเรียน 6 ขวบอ่ะโตแล้วอ่ะโต
แล้วแล้วแม่ก็บอกว่าเออต้องไปโรงเรียน
แล้วนะเราก็ไม่ไม่ได้รู้สึกอะไรนะแต่แค่
รู้สึกว่าสมัยก่อนเราไปโรงเรียนเราก็แค่
ไปที่ไปเรียนใช่มยแล้วก็เล่นกับเพื่อนอื
อือริมจำได้ว่าตอนเรียมอยู่อนุบาลเรียม
ได้เงินไปโรงเรียนวันละ 5 บาท
ค่ะแล้วพอมั้ยคะครูเรียมโอโหพอพอเดี๋ยว
ตอนนั้นน่ะพอครูเรียมครูเรียมเงิน 5 บาท
ตอนนี้เนี่ยถ้าอยู่กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยขึ้นรถ
เมล์ไม่ได้เลยนะคะเออจริงอือซื้ออาหารได้
ม 5 บาทไม่ได้น้ำก็ 6 บาทน่ะนะ 7 บาทอื
ตอนครูหญิงเด็กๆอ่ะน้ำแก้วระบาด
ูน้ำโค้ก
เปปซี่น้ำแดงอะไรอย่างเงี้ยค่ะเหรอตอน
สมัยเดี่ยมอ่ะ 5 บาทแกา
โอ 5 บาทนะแต่ว่าต้องแบบขอแบบพ่อแม่ซื้อ
ให้หน่อยอืมอันนี้น้ำในโรงเรียนนะแบบที่
โรงเรียนขายแก้วละบาทมั้งึประมาณนี้แหละ
แต่ถ้าเกิดเป็นน้ำหวาน
เนี่ย 1 บาท 2 บาทก็มีอ่าแต่ถ้าโค้กก็จะ
แพงหน่อยใช่มอือเห็นมั้ยพอเราพูดถึงอดีต
อ่ะสมัยก่อนเราจะรู้สึกว่าแบบอุ้ยทำไมเรา
แก่จังเลยอ่ะเ้าูหญิงจำได้นะคะว่าตอนสมัย
ก่อนเงี้ยเราไปโรงเรียนเสร็จแล้วก็กลับ
บ้านหรือว่าอ่ะโตโตมาหน่อยมาอยู่กรุงเทพฯ
ก็ได้ตอนมาอยู่กรุงเทพฯอ่ะก็ยังไม่ได้มี
แบบโทรศัพท์อินเทอร์เน็ตอะไรแบบเยอะขนาด
นั้นในราคาถูกที่เราจะสามารถมีโทรศัพท์
มือถือได้อ่ะค่ะตอนครูหญิงโรงเรียนเลิกก็
ไปถ่ายเอ๊ยแต่ตอนนี้มันกลับมาอีกครั้งนึง
แล้วนะไปถ่ายสติ๊กเกอร์อ่ะตู้ถ่าย
สติกเกอร์
เราเราถ่ายสติ๊กเกอร์นี่ครูหญิงต้องต้อง
หยอดเงินกี่
บาทจำไม่ได้แล้วตอนนั้นมันหยอดเงินหรอจำ
ไม่ได้อ่ะค่ะแต่จำได้ว่าโรงเรียนเลิกแล้ว
ก็ไปกับ
เพื่อนเพราะว่าโรงเรียนกับห้างเนี่ยมัน
อยู่ใกล้กันเดินได้เดินไปได้ก็ไม่เป็น
ห้างเนาะเป็นโรงหนังอ่ะค่ะเอาไว้ดูหนัง
แต่ว่ามันก็จะมีแบบ KFC มีแมีอาหารขาย
อย่างเงี้ยค่ะแล้วก็มีตู้ถ่าย
สติกเกอร์ก็คือแบบเราเข้าไปอ่ะค่ะแล้วเรา
ก็ถ่ายแต่ว่ามันไม่ได้มีแบบอะไรให้เลือก
มากขนาดนี้นะมันก็เป็นตู้ถ่ายสติ๊กเกอร์
ที่จะมีฟิลเตอร์นิดหน่อยแล้วก็จะมันมาจาก
ญี่ปุ่นน่ะค่ะมันก็จะเป็นสไตล์แบบน่ารักๆ
เหมือนญี่ปุ่นอืแล้วหน้าเราจะดูแบบน่าจะ
ดูแบบตาโตกลมแบ๊วสวยมากหูครูหญิงก็เอ๊ะ
ครูหญิงเรียนที่จังหวัดอะไรคะตอนเด็กๆ
กรุงเทพฯมัู้้หญิงที่พูดถึงอ่าุหญิงู้
หญิงมากรุงเทพฯถ่ายสติ๊กเกอร์เนี่ยตอน
อายุ 16 อายุ 16 เนี่ยมากรุงเทพฯแต่ตั้ง
แต่อายุ 15 เนี่ยเรียนที่ต่างจังหวัดนะ
ที่ชลบุรีอันนั้นโรงเรียนไม่ได้อยู่ใกล้
อะไรเลยค่ะไม่มีอะไรเลยมีโรงเรียนกับตลาด
เท่านั้นไม่มีอะไรให้ไปเดินช้อปปิ้งไม่มี
ใช่เพราะว่าเรียมกำลังจะบอกเลยว่าเรียม
อยู่ที่มหาสารคามไม่ได้อยู่ในกรุงเทพฯนะ
คะโตขึ้นมานี่ก็คือ 1516 ยังคิดว่ายังไม่
รู้จักเลยนะแบบ Mcdonald  KFC อ๋อเออแบบ
ไม่ไม่แบบไม่ได้สนใจด้วยแล้วมันก็ไม่ได้
อยู่ใกล้เราไม่ได้อยู่
กรุงเทพฯไม่รู้จักอะไรเลยอืเหมือนกันเหม
แค่แบบไปเรียนแล้วตอนนั้นตอนอายุ 15 ก็
ยังไม่ได้ใช้โทรศัพท์อืเหมือนกันค่ะครู
หญิงก็ไม่ได้ใช้นะแต่เพื่อนน่ะมีเพื่อน
บางคนเนี่ยมี
โทรศัพท์มันจะมีโทรศัพท์อยู่ 1 รุ่นน่ะ
อันนี้เป็นโทรศัพท์จริงๆนะคะเป็นของ Sony
อริกันครูหญิงไม่รู้ว่าครูเรียมครูเรียม
อาจจะแบบไม่ทันไม่ทันที่จะได้เห็นรุ่นพี่
มีอ่ะเพราะว่ามันจะเป็นโทรศัพท์แบบประมาณ
ขนาดเนี้ยค่ะแล้วเาจะเวลาที่มันตั้งอยู่
แล้วเวลาที่มีคนโทรหาอ่ะโทรศัพท์มันจะ
สั่นใช่มั้ยแล้วโทรศัพท์มันจะสั่นแล้วมัน
จะเดินได้อ่ะคือแบบอ่ะสมมุติอ่ะสมมุติถ้า
เป็นโทรศัพท์ของเราใช่มั้ยแบบเนี้ยเวลา
มันสั่นมันก็จะสั่นงืดืดปกติใช่มั้ยแต่
Sony  eron ตอนนั้นน่ะมันจะตั้งอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะแล้วเวลามีคนโทรมามันจะสั่นแล้ว
มันเหมือนมันจะเดินน่ะอืมันเป็นอะไรที่
แบบว่าฮิตมากครูหญิงจะจำได้ว่ามีเพื่อนคน
นึงอ่ะเค้ามีโทรศัพท์รุ่นนี้แล้วทุกคน
เนี่ยก็ดูทีวีใช่มั้ยคะแล้วทุกคนก็โทรหา
เค้าเราก็เอาโทรศัพท์เขอ่ะตั้งไว้บนโต๊ะ
แล้วพอเราโทรมันก็จะอืแล้วมันก็จะเดินๆๆๆ
อย่างเงี้ยมันเป็นอะไรที่แบบว้าวมากอ่ะ
ตอนนั้นน่ะตอนที่แบบเรายังเป็นเด็กๆเราก็
แบบอูยโทรศัพท์เดิน
ได้แต่ตอนนี้สิคะโทรศัพท์มันแบบหูถ่ายรูป
ได้ฟังเพลงได้
ทำทุกอย่างได้หมดแล้วอ่ะใช่ๆแล้วคิดว่า
แบบการมาของคอมพิวเตอร์และการมาของ
โทรศัพท์เนี่ยเปลี่ยนโลกเราไปเยอะมากอื
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าอย่างครูหญิงก็คิดว่าครู
เรียมก็เหมือนกันเนาะจากที่ครูเรียมพูดนะ
คะว่าเรา 2 คนไม่ได้โตมากับโทรศัพท์ไม่
ได้โตมากับคอมพิวเตอร์นะเพราะว่าอย่างคุณ
ครูหญิงเนี่ยครูหญิงมีคอมพิวเตอร์ก็คือทำ
งานแล้วนะตอนเรียนหนังสือครูหญิงก็ไม่ได้
ใช้คอมพิวเตอร์นะคะเพราะว่าไม่ได้เรียน
มหาวิทยาลัยที่แบบต้องใช้คอมพิวเตอร์ไง
ใช่อแต่ว่าเด็กๆตอนเนี้ยทุกคนในกระเป๋า
อ่ะมี IPad มีคอมมีโทรศัพท์โทรศัพท์ใช่
ส่วนครูหญิงกับครูเรียมก็คือกระเป๋าใหญ่
มากมีหนังสือหนังสือหนังสือหนังสือหนังือ
แล้วเรียมก็แบ่งไม่เหมือนกันเนาะแบกอยู่
แบบเนี้ยตัวเล็กๆนะเป็นผู้หญิงตัวเล็กๆ
แล้วก็แบกหนังสือไปหลายเล่มมากใช่ค่ะแล้ว
ก็แบบว่าไม่อยากเอาหนังสือไปโรงเรียนเอา
หนังสือไว้ที่โรงเรียนก็ไม่ได้ครู
[เพลง]
ตีทำไมครูต้องให้เด็กๆเนี่ยครูหญิงก็เลย
เตี้ยเลยไงคะต้องแบกหนังสือไปโรงเรียนทุก
วันทุกวันอเป็นเพราะหนังสือ
ใช่นั่นแหละตอนเห็นมมันก็ไม่เหมือนกัน
เนาะตอนแรกๆที่ที่เรียมรู้สึกว่าเออมัน
มันเริ่มมีความแตกต่างจากตอนที่เรารู้จัก
ในสมัยเด็กมันแตกต่างกับสมัยนี้ตอนแรก
เรียมก็รู้สึกว่าไม่อยากถ้ามีลูกไม่อยาก
ให้ลูกโตมากับโทรศัพท์ไม่อยากให้ลูกโตมา
กับสิ่งแบบนี้เลยเพราะเราแบบเรียมไปคิด
ว่าอ๋อเมื่อก่อนมันดีกว่าเราชอบแบบนั้นอ
เราอยากให้แบบเด็กๆเป็นแบบที่เราเคยเป็น
มาก่อนแต่ตอนนี้เรียมก็เลยคิดอีกทีว่าเออ
เค้าก็อยู่ในยุคสมัยของเค้าแล้วมันอาจจะ
มีอะไรที่แบบมันไปไกลกว่านี้ในอนาคตข้าง
หน้าอันเนี้ยก็อาจจะเป็นช่วงที่ความสุข
ของเขาคอีกแบบนึงแล้วแหละอืเพราะว่าเค้า
ก็ไม่เคยมาเห็นชีวิตแบบที่เราเคยเป็นใช่
มั้ยคะที่แบบไม่เคยมีโทรศัพท์ตอนเด็กๆอ่า
ก็คือคือครูหญิงก็จะจำได้ว่าถึงเวลาปุ๊บ
20:00 นครึ่งก็จะมีทีวีดูละครไทยที่ทีวี
ดูละครจบ 22:00 นก็นอนนอนแล้วก็ตื่นนอนมา
ตอนเช้าวันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์ 9:00 นก็ดู
การ์ตูนดูการ์ตูนที่ช่อง 9 อ่าแล้วก็ดู
การ์ตูนดูการ์ตูนดูการ์ตูนอ่าแล้วก็นอน
ตอนกลางคืนแค่เนี้ยคือแบบการได้ดูทีวีก็
คือเป็นเหมือนความบันเทิงของเราอ่ะที่แบบ
ว่ามันเป็นสิ่งที่เราแบบอ้าฉันไม่ต้องไป
โรงเรียนไม่ต้องอ่านหนังสือเป็นเวลาดู
ทีวีก็คือสมัยนั้นติดทีวีก็ยังเป็นเด็ก
ไม่ดีแล้วเลยนะคะก่อนนอนก็ต้องดูกล้วยหอม
จอมซนใช่ B1  B2 เออตื่นเช้ามาวันเสาร์
วันอาทิตย์ก็ต้องดูดิสนีย Club อย่าง
เงี้ยวินนี่ The  Pool แล้วก็ 9:00 นก็ไป
ดูการ์ตูนญี่ปุ่นเหมือนกันเลยซึ่งทุกแล้ว
ก็แบบเราต้องดูอ่ะเพราะว่าถ้าเราไม่ตื่น
มาดูเราก็จะไม่ได้ดูแล้วใช่แต่ตอนนี้ไม่
เป็นไรไงถ้าเราไม่ได้ดูตอนนั้นเรากลับมา
เปิด
YouTube ดูอะไรเราสามารถดูย้อนหลังได้
ใช่แต่ตอนที่ครูหญิงเป็นเด็กๆมันไม่มีนะ
คะนักเรียนคิดว่านักเรียนบางคนก็เหมือน
กันใช่ไหมก็ไม่มีก็คือคุณต้องดูตอนนั้น
ถ้าตอนนั้นเราไม่ได้ดู
ก็ไม่ได้ดูแล้วต้องฟังเพื่อนเล่าเอาคุณ
เรียมก็ต้องถามคู้หญิงเป็นยังไงอ่ะ
เออคือแบบเด็กสมัยนี้เค้าก็แบบส่วนใหญ่ก็
ไม่ค่อยได้ดูทีวีนะไม่เรียมหมายถึงแบบไม่
ได้ดูทีวีตามเวลาที่เ้าฟิกไว้อืแต่ก็จะ
เลือกดูได้จะดูตอนไหนก็ได้
อใช่ก็แบบมีเค้าเรียกเรียกอะไรอ่ะคะมี
แพลตฟอร์มเหรอที่เป็นพวกสตีมมิ่งหนัง
ซีรีย์ให้ดูเยอะๆแล้วแบบเวลาเราเป็นเด็กๆ
อ่ะเราก็ต้องดูทีวีใช่มยสมมุติดูรายการ
ทีวีมีละครสมมุติมีการ์ตูนแล้วกันมี
การ์ตูนเนี่ย 3 นาทีก็พักเบรคโฆษณา 1
นาทีเราก็จะแบบไม่อยากดูโฆษณาเลยอ่ะเราก็
จะเปลี่ยนช่องเปลี่ยนช่องเสร็จเราก็กลับ
มาแต่บางครั้งเราเปลี่ยนช่องนาน
เรากลับมาเอ้ามันเล่นไปแล้วอย่างเงี้ยมัน
ต้องดูโฆษณาตอนนั้นน่ะ 1 นาทียิ่งถ้าทีวี
รายการไหนแบบฮิตมากๆโฆษณาก็เยอะมากๆอืใช่
แต่ตอนนี้เราก็จะแต่จริงๆนะมันก็เหมือนทำ
ให้เรารู้รู้จักการรออ่ะเออเพราะเราต้อง
รอ 2 นาทีเพื่อที่จะได้ดู
การ์ตูนใช่แต่เด็กๆก็จะมองว่าแบบอ๋อเด็กๆ
ตอนนี้เาไม่ต้องดูโฆษณาก็ได้เพราะพวก
โปรแกรมหรือว่าแพลตฟอร์มต่างๆเนี่ยเรา
จ่ายเงินสำหรับไม่ดูโฆษณาไงอืใช่แล้วก็
ทุกอย่างจะเร็วเร็วมากขึ้นแล้วเรียมก็รู้
สึกว่าเออตอนเนี้ยแม้แต่ผู้ใหญ่นะไม่ใช่
แค่เด็กก็จะรู้สึกว่ารอไม่ได้อืมใช่ข้าม
ไปรอไม่ได้ไม่ไม่อือไม่อยากเสียเวลาอื
เหมือน YouTube บางครั้งมีโฆษณาประมาณ 5
วินาทีอ่ะ 5  4  3  2  1 อย่างเงี้ยเราก็
รอะสิสิสิเราจะกดข้ามกดข้ามใช่ 5 วินาที
ก็นานนะสำหรับตอนนี้ใช่นั่นแหละค่ะมันก็
ไม่เหมือนกันไงใช่มสมัยก่อนเนี่ยทีวีมัน
เหมือนกับอหูมันเป็นสิ่งที่แบบเราถ้าเรา
อยากดูต้องดูตอนนี้ทีวีพูดอะไรก็คือจริง
ใช่มยเราจะเชื่อที่ทีวีพูดใช่แต่พูดถึง
แล้วมันก็แบบมีทั้งข้อดีข้อเสียมีทั้ง
เรื่องดีๆแล้วก็เรื่องที่ไม่ดีของแต่ละ
ยุคสมัยด้วยเนาะอืใช่ค่ะอย่างสมัยนี้มัน
ก็ดีตรงที่ว่าถ้าเมื่อก่อนอย่างเงี้ย
เมื่อก่อนสมมุติว่าครูเรียมมีพี่แล้วพี่
ต้องไปเรียนที่เชียงใหม่ครูเรียมอยู่
มหาสาอย่างเงี้ยครูเรียมคิดถึงพี่ก็ต้อง
เขียนจดหมายใช่แล้วก็ต้องรอใช่ไหมเอ๊
เมื่อไหร่พี่จะปิดเทอมกลับบ้านแต่ตอนนี้
ไม่เป็นไรมีวิโอคอใช่มมีเ Time ที่เราแบบ
ออได้เห็นหน้ากันใช่ๆแต่ว่าข้อดีของเขียน
จดหมายก็คืออาจจะเป็นแบบเก็บไว้ได้แล้วก็
เอามาเปิดดูอีกทีนึงแล้วก็รู้สึกดีมันมัน
มีความรู้สึกหลายอย่างอ่ะในแต่ละยุคสมัย
ไหมันก็แบบเอารวมๆกันมามันก็แบบมันก็
สมบูรณ์แบบที่สุดแล้วแหละมันก็เพอเฟคใน
แต่ละช่วงเวลาแล้วแหละใช่ค่ะเพราะว่า
อย่างสมมุติอย่างตอนนี้อย่างเราเนี่ยเกิด
มากับยุคในการเขียนเราก็จะยังรู้จักการ
เขียนน่ะแต่เด็กๆเพิมพ์พิมพ์อ่ะแล้วอ่า
โทรศัพท์มันจะมี aut  correct ให้อ่ะค่ะ
การมี a  correct อ่ะมันทำให้เราแบบจำคำ
ไม่ได้นะเพราะว่าเราไม่ได้พิมพ์เองไงพอ
เรากดมันขึ้นมาเราก็กดกดกดเออแต่ถ้าเรา
เขียนอ่ะมันจำได้ว่าอ๋อมะม่วงเขียนยังไง
มันก็ต่างกันไงอืเรารู้สึกว่าเราคุย
เรื่องนี้ได้นานมากเลยนะคะครีงเพราะว่า
เราแก่แล้วนะคะครูเรียนแต่ว่าเวลาก็หมด
แล้วคุยจนเวลาหมดก็ยังไม่จบยังไม่จบค่ะ
เพราะว่าอะไรที่มันเป็นสมัยก่อนกับสมัย
นี้ในยุคครูหญิงแล้วก็ครูเตรียมมันก็ไม่
เหมือนกันอีกอ่ะแหละแล้วก็หรือว่านัก
เรียนใช่มมันก็ไม่เหมือนกันอแล้วก็คุยกัน
ได้อืหรือว่านักเรียนเหมือนเรามยอืเขียน
จดหมายรอดูทีวีอะไรอย่างเงี้ยถ้าเหมือน
กันก็คอมเมนต์บอกได้นะคะได้เลยค่ะแต่ว่า
วันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนล่ะค่ะหมดเวลาแล้วได้
ค่ะแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วีีดีโอหน้า
นะคะได้เลยค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียน